the North remembers we know no king but
the King in the north whose name is
stark I don't care if he's a busted that
starts blood runs through his veins
he's my king from this day until his
last day what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another game of Thrones
foreshadowing video today I want to talk
about a few different scenes from season
7 because they could be foreshadowing
how certain storylines will end next
season as I'm sure most of you know I
have made a couple foreshadowing videos
before where I talked about some older
scenes and whether or not they were
giving us clues about how Game of
Thrones could end well today I only want
to talk about some of the scenes that
took place during season 7 even though
Dan and Dave no longer have George's
source material to pull from that
doesn't mean they haven't dropped a few
clues as to how the series will
eventually end so let's take a look at
some of the scenes from last season the
first scene I want to show you took
place during season 7 episode 3 this was
when Jaime Lannister and Lady Olenna
spoke for the last time
Jaime was able to sack Highgarden with
the help of the tarly's and once he was
inside the castle he has a private
conversation with Lady Olenna right
before he gives her the poison to drink
during this conversation Lady Olenna
says something to Jaime that could be
foreshadowing his own fate take a look
at this video clip then I will give you
a few of my own thoughts on what this
could mean you love her you really do
love her you she'll be the end of you
possibly not much to be gained from
discussing it with you though so as you
can see Jaime and Alana we're talking
about Cersei and this is when lady Elena
tells Jaime that Cersei will be the end
of him
then Jaime says possibly now I know this
might sound a little confusing to some
people because as of right now Jaime and
Cersei are no longer together Jaime
Lannister is currently on his way north
to help fight in the Great War but we
all know this will not be the last time
Jaime and Cersei see each other based on
Daenerys Targaryen vision from the house
of the undying it's pretty obvious that
an attack when King's Landing is
inevitable and Jaime Lannister will be
there too
besides Cersei Lannister has always said
she would burn cities down to the ground
she had proven this when she burnt down
the Sept of Baelor and when Cersei
realizes she can no longer have King's
Landing she will make sure no one else
can have it either when Cersei deployed
the wildfire reserves under the septa
bail or Cersei not only murdered a whole
lot of innocent people but she also
committed the very action that Jaime
ruined his reputation to prevent if push
comes to shove what Jaime just stand by
and allow Cersei to blow up King's
Landing and potentially kill 1 million
innocent lives or what he put a stop to
this like he had done in the past I
would like to think that Jaime would
kill Cersei have given the chance under
these circumstances but how would this
lead to Jaime's death because that's
what lady Elena was insinuating the
Queen of thorns warned Jaime that his
beloved sister will lead him to his
death but how the main reason why I
wanted to talk about this possibility is
because it completely goes against my
own prediction or theory about how
Jaime's story ends I'm sure most of you
already know but I have always believed
that Jaime would die during the process
of saving brain Stark's life in some way
since Jamie's story arc basically began
when he pushed bran out of the window I
always thought it would come full circle
and end which means Jaime would
sacrifice his own life to save brands
but if what Lady Elena says is true then
this might not be the case depending on
how you want to look at it I think most
people do believe that Jaime will be the
valonqar which is the little brother who
will kill Cersei
according to Maggy the Frog so just for
the sake of this argument let's say Lady
Olenna is right and let's say Jaime is
even the valonqar if both of these
things end up being true then I think
there are a few ways this could play out
during the season 7 finale we already
saw Jaime coming very close to being
killed by Gregor Clegane
in fact when Cersei gave him the signal
to pull out his sword
I actually thought Jaime was going to
die in that moment but I am glad he did
not die because he still has his pages
to fill in the white book however this
doesn't mean the mountain won't
eventually kill him in the end
if Jaime ends up fulfilling the valonqar
prophecy then perhaps the mountain
inflicts a fatal wound on Jaime right
before he is able to kill Cersei and
save King's Landing
or perhaps Jaime kills himself right
after he kills Cersei I don't think we
can rule this out just yet be
sides if you've read all the books then
you would know jaime and cersei dying
together has been hinted at on more than
one occasion by both of these characters
Jaime has said that he could not die
while Cersei still lived we will die
together as we were born together if
Jaime doesn't happen to be the one who
killed Cersei that I think there is a
very good chance it could be done by
euron greyjoy even if he doesn't
strangle her like the prophecy states
there are a number of different ways he
could get Cersei out of his way
there is another scene I wanted to show
you from that same episode and this was
when Cersei was meeting with the
representative from the iron bank at
some point next season Euron Greyjoy
might betray Cersei Lannister and even
kill her what Tyco said to Cersei could
be foreshadowing how her story
ultimately comes to an end there was
actually two different things he said to
Cersei that leads me to believe she will
lose even more allies next season first
let's take a look at what he said about
your own Greyjoy I decapitated the
Dornish snake my Armada owned the Narrow
Sea
Yulin Greyjoy's Armada as there's been
great joy is loyal to me for now
today's Targaryen has three full-grown
dragons how well the wooden ships fare
against fire-breathing dragons her
dragons might not be as informal as
something I think Tycho's basically said
what all of us have been thinking
Cersei might have Euron's loyalty as of
right now but how long will this last
everyone knows your own cannot be
trusted and I'm sure his patience and
faith in Cersei is running thinner by
the day he has already went above and
beyond to help Cersei to feed her
enemies but he has yet to receive
anything in return
now that Jaime is gone Cersei may become
even more desperate and Euron may sees
this as an opportunity to position
himself even closer to sitting on the
Iron Throne in one of the sample
chapters from the winds of winter it
says one of the visions Aaron sees after
he is forced to drink shade of the
evening is of euron greyjoy sitting on
the Iron Throne looking more squid than
human and beside him stands a shadow in
woman's form long and tall and terrible
her hands alive with pale white fire
maybe that's a reference to Circe using
wildfire as we saw one the show perhaps
it is foreshadowing that Euron will sit
on the Iron Throne even if for a brief
amount of time I think this is something
we have to take into consideration now
whether you're on actually turns on
Circe or not is up for debate but I also
know some of you have been wondering
what will happen with the golden company
I want to show you another short clip
from Tycho's and Circe's conversation
because it could be foreshadowing the
future of the iron banks relationship
with Circe so take a look at what he
says the iron bank appreciates how you
cast off the yoke of superstition
freeing the crown from elements who
sought to subvert the rule of law the
destruction of the Sept of Baelor was a
tragic accident
indeed but sometimes tragedies are
necessary to restore order and rational
leadership the embankments is gold back
your father never minced words either
but yes your debts are considerable I
wanted to save this clip for last
because I thought it was the most
interesting one in my opinion because I
have considered Euron and/or Jaime
killing Cersei for quite some time but
this part of the conversation could be
hinting at what the iron bank ultimately
does the only fighting chance Cersei has
is if she gets the going company on her
side but if the iron bank decides to
shift their alliance then obviously
Cersei is completely screwed
now what Cersei said during that scene
was what happened to the septa bail or
was a tragic accident
but what Tyco said in response could
reveal his true intentions Tyco said yes
sometimes tragedies are necessary to
restore order and rational leadership
now does it sound like Cersei fits that
description
can order be restored with Cersei and
power an issue a rational leader
absolutely not in the iron bank knows
this they also know Cersei doesn't have
a very good chance at winning the war
later in this conversation he even
voices his concern about your own
Greyjoy's allegiance he knows your own
cannot be trusted and even if he can he
says what good are his wooden ships
against fire-breathing dragons we all
know the answer to this because we saw
what our dragon
had done to the ships and marine I think
the iron bank could be secretly working
out a new deal behind the scenes and
it's a deal that won't involve Cersei
Lannister losing cause many people have
already predicted the golden company
will turn their back on Cersei by
swearing fealty to the Targaryen in what
Tycho's said during that conversation
maybe the foreshadowing for this plot
twist it would actually be kind of cool
if Iran did what Tywin did to the Mad
King rape before Ned arrived in King's
Landing Tywin and his men were given
access inside the city gates and once
they were inside they started butchering
all of the mad king's men and family
this was when the mountain killed
Rhaegar and Elias children when Euron
shows up with the golden company he
could do the exact same thing the city
watch will allow him to enter because
they are under the impression that him
and Cersei are allies but once he's
inside he could take over the city and
Cersei wouldn't be able to do much about
it regardless of how it plays out I
don't see Cersei making it out of the
season alive her downfall is inevitable
but it's always fun trying to guess who
will be the one to take her down for
good let me know your thoughts on all of
this do you think Lady Olenna was right
when she said Cersei will be the
downfall for Jaime Lannister do you
think Tycho's was right when he
suggested Euron won't stay loyal for
long and do you think the iron bank is
planning on sending the golden company
elsewhere put your comments down below I
appreciate each and every one of you for
watching the video the support seems to
be growing stronger and I cannot thank
you all enough there will be another
giveaway announced in my next video so
make sure you come back and watch that
one to find out all the details also I
want to thank everyone on patreon for
continuing to support my channel the
long night is almost over and I love you
because your support has never wavered
have a great day I will see you again
very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]